mais finalement je me demande ce que
vous êtes prête à faire par amour pour
un homme vous êtes prête à faire
beaucoup pour un homme oui oui on va
voir interview par amour
[Musique]
est ce que
est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous déguiser en
elton john
oui oui avec les lunettes la perruque et
ouais ouais ouais est-ce que par un mot
vous seriez prête à prendre de la drogue
comme
mais non et non parce que j'ai j'ai pu
pas aimer un homme que me demande ça
va s'arrêter quand même est-ce que par
amour si votre trois mêmes les rues
basses les botero est ce que vous seriez
prête à prendre 17 kg botero ses 117
pages de signal est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
les chaussettes sales de votre mari ah
oui oui
c'est bien est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête par un mot à accepter
quelques petites infidélités
mais juste un peu non non mr un peu non
non non vous pas rien à faire même pas
pas de maîtresse tout ça vous n'êtes pas
par amour mais qui ça le rend heureux si
vous l'aimez mais non mais non
mais non mais moi j'ai pas aimé non
comme ça donc vous n'êtes pas d'accord
pour vivre à trois avec la maîtresse il
n'y a pas d'accord pour aller dans les
clubs échangistes avec la maîtresse il
n'y a rien à faire non même par amour
mais non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
sa dépendent vous n'êtes pas contre la
ça dépend ça sera contre nous mais oui
je dépends de quoi si vous aussi vous
voulez mais vous avez vous demande de
ça je trouve que c'est un peu une
interview stupide
je vous disais aussi
hansen entièrement d'accord ces
tendances m on ne demande pas on est on
est une esclave sans avoir besoin d'eux
mais pourquoi l'esclave en plus il ya
des choses bien fait et c'est quelque
chose que je sais pas moi je n'aime pas
ça marche pas comme ça
mathieu gines bien
m'aimer mais j'aime bien aussi peut-être
je viens à péter jamais bien un petit
peu être soumise comme un programme est
appâtée qu'il ya une chose a décidé
d'être quelque chose c'est une chose ou
alors ça c'est un autre type de jeu
et c'est une chose caution et un jus
cocciante à la salle ça peut être aussi
drôle a pour un moment mais c'est moi
que je décide d'accord quand tu veux les
corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus